It all started with this one young girl who sent me this video...
...of herself singing one of my choral pieces.
And I was struck so hard by the beauty, the intimacy of it, the sweetness of it.
And I thought, well, it would be amazing if we can get a hundred people to do this...
...and cut it altogether and make a virtual choir.
So, I then went into a studio and I conducted in total silence.
I can only hear it in my head, and I loaded all of that up to YouTube,...
...and I sent out a call to singers across the world,...
...and the response was totally overwhelming.
We had 185 singers from 12 different countries.
It was all about connecting and about somehow connecting...
...with these people over the world and these individuals, alone, together.
For me, singing together and making music together...
...is a fundamental human experience.
And I love the idea that technology can bring people together...
...from all over the world and still sort of participate...
...in this transcending experience.